I think the question on everyone's minds
is how did Cape Town getcha 2013 which
was only five years ago we had the
record rainfall year where lots and lots
of water dams were full 2014 we had a
drop in those danced when we got to 1st
of October which is the end of the rainy
season in 2015 we had dams after 78
percent for in 2016 there were 58
percent for in 2017 there were 38
percent for who knows what they're going
to be at the end of 2018
this year's rainy
[Music]
[Music]
what does it look like when the chaps
around John 10,000 people running down a
highway burning tires stopping traffic
to protest at the fact that they're not
getting their service delivery airports
being cut off
tourism closing down people choosing not
to visit here unemployment shooting
through-the-roof Petroleum closing down
the harbour closing down ships can't
come here they can't get refills of
water and that's what they come here for
part from off loading and unloading mass
exodus of the people who can afford to
move out move out meaning that much of
his money gets spent in the center it is
a catastrophe and we gotta start using
the right wording it's a catastrophe
it's not a crisis a crisis as a
temporary whoops a catastrophe is when
the police are moving into the
distribution points the Army is moving
into the distribution points your water
will be given to you and the the
protection of a gun that's heavy stuff
that's a completely different so it's an
Armageddon top scenario we cannot afford
to get to that place any way in the
world
and this is absolute disaster when she
said to me that all that is the perfect
time for one party $2 for my main
information that were nationally do to
me it's not helping anybody
[Music]
to the scientific community very well
[Music]
we've been through so much in this in
this country it's a hard life we've come
from a difficult part the gang it a
difficult future it might just be that
no water or very little water or zero
water is the thing that actually brings
us together
[Music]
the rest of the world will look to
Capetown for what we did wrong our doing
wrong and what we did right and our
doing right and that will be the
blueprint going forward for eternity
[Music]
you
[Music]